hello and welcome to another exciting
edition of instant trailer review i'm
j.s i'm jeff and today we are going to
look at the interstellar teaser trailer
and oh what a tease it is
so
green band uh let's get that out of the
way
okay
interesting stuff up front because we
have paramount and warner brothers which
is really rare to see two major studios
both finance the film usually one will
take four and one will take domestic
but this one if you've done your
research this was all done for a very
special deal between paramount and
warren brothers which also included
rights to the friday 13th franchise and
of course south park so
obviously there's a lot of trust between
these two major studios to exchange that
much and of course christopher nolan
who's had a great success with warner
brothers
i mean
this has to be
much more than just a pet project yeah
if they're having two major studios back
this right so i mean after the batman
trilogy and the huge success that was
inception everyone wanted a piece of the
pie it's true and so yeah i mean they
struck a deal and it's pretty
interesting we'll see what happens with
those other two ips um well let's get
into this
here we have some uh nice b-roll from
science we need to find ourselves
okay
so
we immediately start hearing this
matthew mcconaughey voiceover what what
are your initial impressions on this i
love his voice
here's the you open up in the middle of
a wheat field with his southern accent
he sounds like a farm boy so he's just
so at this oh yeah he definitely fits
that yeah
um
but i get the feeling that i can
watching harvest of shame here
grapes are rather yeah
you know one of those like old cbs
documentaries about corn and corn
actually plays a vital role in the plot
of interstellar i'm not kidding really
yeah okay for energy or just yeah okay
so
i mean we'll we'll see some of these
scenes um more archival footage this is
when they're breaking the sound barrier
right maybe the late 40s early 50s so
and of course when we go up into outer
space with the mercury missions and then
we're going to apollo
to reach for the stars
i love that to reach for the stars um
well you know what here's the his accent
works because he sounds sort of just
like midwest all-american you know
good-looking guy talking about the sort
of incredible pride the country had
doing space travel i mean and not to
mention a lot of the guys who did go
into space we're all sort of classic you
know midwestern kind of american guys
sure american heroes
yeah but
my main complaint with this is you could
put all of this in front of almost any
sci-fi film you know well that's one
thing i will say that like all this
footage is incredibly fascinating but
it's not from the movie so it's just
so but they are trying to make a
correlation between obviously america's
great achievements in space travel and
of course now that we're kind of going
back as we sure and here we start seeing
some of the actual about a minute and 20
seconds we actually get into the movie
now
so i mean he looks pretty sad i think
it's safe to say well let's be honest i
mean matthew mcconaughey he's he's just
going for oscar gold now if you look at
what he's been doing the last couple
years he's proven himself to be a a
great actor he's on a roll he is and now
he's worked with christopher nolan so
obviously his stars is
yeah
um
i love this shot right here this is such
a classic like almost spielberg kind of
shot gilbert was attached to this
project for a few years he was yeah okay
then it went to nolan so
and then there's the title interstellar
has the
father and child are watching a rocket
take up one year
so this trailer
teaser trailer came out last week um the
definition of a teaser trailer last week
was an incredible week for sci-fi
trailers oh yeah we've got we're
ascending godzilla
um edge of tomorrow that's right and
this as well and i thought this would be
showing before the hobbit it didn't show
before my screening which is pretty
surprising um well here's the thing
though from i mean because this trailer
it doesn't because they reveal very
little it doesn't look like it would
just from this trailer you can tell it
doesn't seem it would appeal to a big
box office sort of sci-fi adventure
crowd because it shows very very little
it's the definition of a teaser
sure but um
the whole thing with the footage i mean
it almost makes it feel like they don't
have anything yet because they say well
we're gonna shoot archive footage for
two-thirds of the trailer and show you
nothing of then the only thing from the
trailer from the movie that shows
anything with actual space is just that
one rocket ship right other than that
it's just mathematically crying as he
leaves the farm so on the one hand i
love it when trailers don't give away
the plot and especially second act third
third act stuff right um but on the
other hand you've really given me
nothing to be excited about for this
movie other than what i had going in
which is of course christopher nolan's
involvement the incredible cast i mean
let's look at
this last page here we have
okay matthew mcconaughey anne hathaway
jessica chastain um
michael can you have almost everybody in
this movie is or at least will be
mathematical eventually will be oscar
nominated oscar winners um you obviously
have i mean christopher nolan's name
alone sells yeah it obviously sells so i
mean i mean he practically almost looked
like the director of man of steel even
though he was only the producer
yeah and han zimmer's gonna be returning
to and it's gonna be in theaters and
imax i believe november 7th right next
year so it's i mean it's too early to
judge it's still just a teaser but
i mean
it's it's too hard to judge right now
but they but i do like the idea the
message they're trying to send where
they're trying to correlate you know
modern space travel with our classic
american roots and you know and our
desire to to explore so i like the
correlation and it's yeah we're going
back to that but they're just not giving
us enough to really judge just yet i can
appreciate that but to me it doesn't
look any more than like a super bowl
commercial and not necessarily for a
movie so
um those are our thoughts what do you
think about the interstellar teaser
trailer let us know in the comments
below thanks i'm j.s i'm jeff
catch you next time
you